what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends we butchered
that one but
hello everybody and welcome back to
unwax with your favorite sisters sophia
and sistine stallone
hi everybody i hope you're having a
beautiful tuesday
i hope your weekend was wonderful and
you're going back to those zoom calls
those nine to five i hope you're on zoom
smile on your face
with the hangover in your body feeling
good because
definitely justine and i are hungover is
that what you're doing
in the past couple no i mean uh we don't
drink often and go out i mean also it is
a
quarantine and we can't not really do
much but is it weird that i
look forward to the hangover because we
really never go
yeah we never know it's not that we
never go out because we can't go out but
it's we never drink
yes and for a 22 and 24 year old
i was like you know what i need to have
more fun because when i drink
i am fun she is fun i'm fun together
we're fun we're fun it's crazy no but
it's funny because we said before here
we're in florida
so it is totally different regulations i
mean we do follow the guidelines
according to
location but in florida restaurants are
open and so
i would like to just call out sistine
for giving
someone my number oh ladies and
gentlemen hold on
not just a person i know it's someone i
don't know that i didn't want to give
them my number
hold on i need to explain and now they
won't stop calling me
no no see i know the unwaxers will
understand where i'm coming from when i
explained
the story obviously let me set the scene
there's this cute little kid following
sophia around like a puppy pies
cute little kid cute
little kid need i remind you
i have a few drinks in we're ready to go
home this kid
follows sophia outside and
he goes because you look like jessica
alba first of all
what woman wouldn't want that compliment
so i'm over here like
melting on the sidewalk oh my god that
is so cute
because oh no and this is the thing so c
just thinks he left the place just
casually just to tell me i looked like
jessica alba
when in fact five minutes before that
when i was walking to the restroom
he comes up to me and goes do you think
i'm hot i go
i like your outfit and then he goes
wanna make out oh my gosh i didn't know
this and i say sir
no thank you but have a nice night so i
leave
so we leave i didn't know this happened
right
i thought oh my god someone
complimenting you
how cute plus i want to say now that i
know he did that
i respect the boldness i do you respect
the boldness that's where we're
different see
i wouldn't want a guy to be like let's
make out but i like that comes up to you
and says do you think i'm handsome
that's funny that's pretty funny that's
kind of an odd question so
yeah i mean look it was he very
confident and forward
yes do i respect it sure
there is a limit to the confidence
though but
especially let me just give some content
let me just give some context i'm not
throwing your numbers out here
let me give context we're outside now
ready we're waiting to go home
he's talking sophia is sort of just
keeping to yourself quiet
as because i'm not interested as a
responsible sister
i start grilling him because i need to
know what's this kid's deal right
so i'm asking him a hundred questions
i'm like what's your sign
where are you from what's your job do
you have any brothers
what's your shoe size what are you
wearing tommy bahama i'm asking him
everything
all right and sophia's like no no not
interested
he follows us to the car no he doesn't
follow us to the car
i leave the situation i'm letting her
talk to him because i'm like you know
what
i'm not interested i want to go home
i've had three cocktails
i'm good to me he's saying really nice
things about you and i like to hear that
sistine let's just say for what it was
you thought it was funny to give him my
number
and so even though he's a nice guy he
won't stop calling me
i thought he deserved it this is what's
annoying
this is what's annoying and i actually
ended up if we're gonna be on wax i was
super pissed off at her
because i was really pissed obvious it's
my personal number it's not something
just to give out
for one thing two i never said i was
interested the scene just said
he's super nice and funny so here you go
this is for you
and three now i get up and i wake up to
text messages
what are you doing to hey what are you
doing today he calls me oh this is the
best part you guys
and this is a this is a friendly
reminder to those out there if you ever
consider danny s this is the one thing
you should not do
the first sentence first of all i didn't
put his number in so i just answered the
phone
and it ended up being him it's like hey
well that's your fault you shouldn't
answer numbers if you don't have sales
uh you never know sometimes i kind of
like answering the random numbers
because it could be interesting but
i answered the phone and he goes i just
have to say before i start talking
i had no idea your dad was sylvester
stallone
like my uncle and brother
and grandpa's passwords are all rambo
and he's going on and look i i have to
say i'm not i'm don't want to sound
bratty because
it is i really do appreciate it i agree
my dad's a badass he worked hard for and
i
gladys fans i'm glad he was one too but
if you think that's a good way to get my
attention
and for me to say yes to go on a date
with you not a good move buddy
but overall he is nice
he was very forward and confident great
story now but now he
would like to interject really fast in
my head
drunken state of mind i thought this
could be the start of something new
all we talk about on the show is how
single and how sad we are
and how we want to meet cute um okay so
we have a super super fun guest coming
on her name is caitlin bristow she was
on the bachelor she did dance with the
stars
super cool great girl she's hilarious i
am
so excited to meet her yes and um this
conversation i know is going to be great
so stay tuned
you guys she is the dancing with the
stars champ
was on season 11 of the bachelorette
she's a podcast host of her very own
show called off the vine
and has a wine club and label called
spade and spares this is the beautiful
and hilarious caitlyn bristow ladies and
gentlemen yes
i clap for myself i usually just yeah
absolutely
sound effects will do it all honestly
when i was writing this out i was like
oh my gosh is there a wine label
i no idea that's a dream it's literally
probably my favorite
it's the one thing i'm the most proud of
and my favorite thing that i've ever
done
because i'm obsessed with wine and it's
like how did you get into wine
i honestly i used to work at a
restaurant like i did for about 10 years
and i was trying my goal i was like well
i had to give up on dancing when i was
in my early 20s then i went through a
relationship
breakup i came back i was like i'm gonna
work my way up
in a restaurant i'm gonna become a gm
that's what i'm gonna do
and i loved learning about wine i always
got to learn from like this incredible
sommelier
and then i had to teach uh people about
wine and wine pairings and
know everything about it because i was
training servers and i just fell in love
with
wine knowledge and i lived in vancouver
which
my parents had a lake house in okanagan
which is wine
heaven and so i just loved it i fell in
love with everything about it and when i
got a podcast after the show it was i
mean around drinking wine i was always
drinking wine and i was
doing something about this where i'm
like i have my own wine label that's
awesome
would you consider yourself a
connoisseur no no
why not i would say so i heard that the
test to become like an
official wine connoisseur sommelier is
super super hard
it's i've read that somewhere there's a
test yeah you have to like be able to
smell a glass of wine and know like the
year
and the region
it's next level so i'm i'm honestly i'm
really not picky i
i mostly like all wine i'm starting to
become a little bit of a wine snob with
my
um okay we say we're coffee coffee stops
i'm gonna snob with everything
i'm drinking we're so snobby with our
gum everything
i hate the gum that's like sandy i'm
really into the mentos
um that's the one girl that's the number
one
maybe number one connoisseur she gets it
you guys she gets it
she got something literally obsessed
with it but we're so jealous because i
was thinking about how much wine you
probably got to taste
and even just go through all these
testers at your house and like thinking
what did
how did you think of spade and sparrows
okay so
first of all that is a fun part of the
job but it gets like
almost your mouth turns raw from tasting
so much wine that you're like i don't
even know like i had to switch my cab
that i picked
to a completely different one because
the next day i tasted it and i was like
oh look at her oh right yeah oh my god
um yeah
yeah don't do that because then you get
too drunk and then you're like oh why
did i pick that one that's stupid yeah
exactly
but sweden sparrows was honestly i was
sitting in napa
at this place called goose and gander
it's one of my favorite places it's just
this little hole in the wall
and i was just trying to come up with a
name and i was sitting with my business
partner and my girlfriend
and we were like let's just write down
every single thing that comes to mind
whether it's like an inside joke with my
mom or my friend or something yeah
right like reminds me of myself or like
my tattoos or anything
and so we're just writing down we had a
list of like hundreds of words
and we're actually going between because
my grandma used to always call me kiss
me kate
and so i was like oh that's a cute wine
name and yeah
going back and forth and then i had a
spade i love playing cards with my
family it's
every time i go home we play cards for
hours and hours and hours and i always
love
the spade in the deck because it's the
strongest
uh suit and so i have that word written
down
and then i have my tattoos and sparrows
and they're the bird that remember how
to fly home so i was just
connecting a couple things that i was
like sweet and sparrow sounds pretty
badass
it does kind of stuck that's i feel like
i could never
it's like getting a tattoo like i would
never be able to decide
on what to name something what to do i
just [ __ ] go
i'm like no i wish i was more like you
wait what
well how many tattoos do you have i
think i have 11
but they're all your favorite what's
your least favorite okay well my least
favorite is definitely i have tear drops
here so i could go so so stupid
i was like that's what i would get i
would get a finger mustache and just
that's what i would
i don't know why i ended up going with a
tear i got stopped at a border once and
like almost couldn't get back into
canada because they thought i was like a
drug dealer
oh my god that's right i was like gang
related but okay
that's probably my worst one my favorite
one um
is probably oh you know what it's my
rose um
my rose that i have on my arm oh
beautiful well our middle name is rose
so we always thought we were like
should we get a tattoo with like rose
for us or something
maybe we coffee with the rose yeah you
should i never in my life thought i
would get a rose tattooed on me after
coming off the bachelorette i was like
[ __ ] roses sorry can i swear on this
podcast yes yes
we do yes oh okay i was like yeah [ __ ]
i was like i never want to see what
again and then after a while i was like
okay you know what that was a pretty
pivotal time in my life that opened up
so many doors and experiences and like i
stopped being so
negative about it and i was like okay
rose tattooed on me oh my god you know
that's such a good transition because i
have so many questions
about the show more so what happens
logistically like for example one of my
questions is
um when you are at the first row
ceremony and there's so many guys there
yeah how do you i have a theory she says
this every single time she watches the
show
how do you remember everyone's names and
this is my career
this is my theory every time and i see
this we're watching
matt james is that his name right yeah
yes so he does this too
and i notice this with a lot of them
every time before they say the name out
loud they pick up the rose they look
down at the stem and then they look up
and say the name and i'm convinced
the name is on the rose because i just
like absolutely
no how do you remember that would
actually be a lot easier i don't know
why they don't do that
um but it's actually just like the magic
of tv where they
you go in you say four names that you
have memorized
and then you go back into a back room
and then pick another four and then you
come
and say those four and then you go back
yeah that makes so much sense that does
make sense edit out the parts where
you're leaving the room but it was so
funny because i'll never forget
some of the names i'd call i'd be like i
have no idea who ryan is but i know i'm
calling his name
so that's i think sometimes while you
look down you're like ryan and then the
guy walks where you're like oh right
that guy
oh no no no i would go ryan i'm over
here oh
oh ryan that's probably why we're
looking down
that's so it's like you're not nervous
you're just like waiting for someone to
walk out before you look up
and i don't remember that is so funny so
we've had a few
um old bachelor contestants come on the
show and i asked all of them the same
question
what did your life look like before
joining the show
and like what made you what was the
final shot that made you sign up i mean
it was i i was dating this guy
who i totally thought he was the one who
moved to germany he was a hockey player
and i just
i was oh [ __ ] yeah you went to germany
for
and hockey players all right i did i did
i'm that girl i did it
and i love it i love that i like living
in germany just like the most depressed
i've ever
in my life i i reminded myself like of
my 12 year old self i was a child i
would like
cry over everything i'd have hissy fits
i couldn't hear people's like
conversations
and i couldn't work and he was always
gone and i had no time
there oh my gosh i was such a shell of
myself and it sucked
and so we ended up breaking up and i
came home and i'd always worked in the
restaurant industry because
i always wanted to um be a dancer so i
i was in ballet my whole life i
moved to vancouver from the small town i
grew up in to
dance with the company there and i
thought that's what i was going to do
but
um i wasn't good enough let's just put
it out there and then i chased a boy
and then when i came back from a breakup
i was like i have no apartment i have no
money
i have no job i have no education i have
no career
yeah i feel like it was i was miserable
but determined
so after i was like you know i was rock
bottom there for a while i was living
with my parents i was
like crying every day couldn't get out
of bed and eventually how old were you
at the time
i was 27. okay yeah and so i was like
i just have to start over this is awful
but i was like i'm gonna
move my way up in the restaurant biz
that's just what i'm going to do because
that's what i can do i know i'm good at
it i know i'm capable of gold i think
that's really important
yeah and i did and i went for it and i
just worked my way up in this restaurant
and
i was confident in that industry just
because i'd done it for so long
and my girlfriend was convinced i should
go on the bachelor
and i always wanted to do something like
like i'm a risk taker i don't
worry too much about failure i'm like
i'll do whatever like i'm very
spontaneous and she
was like we should get you on the
bachelor and i was like oh my gosh yes
then i could like build
something and like have an empire yeah
like
in my head i'm like i'm not gonna find
love but maybe i'll find a career
and honestly i feel like that's really
small yeah
that's a really smart way to look and
that's why everybody does it everyone
does that you hope to fall in love you
hope to find that that would that's
obviously a bonus if you can but
yeah so i was i was working at a
restaurant i was teaching
spin classes and i was working with um
this um organization called raw beauty
talks which if you don't know what that
is you should definitely look into it
um it's is that a puppy in the back
sorry my mom mom mom
she just goes she just goes someone got
bit by a catfish on her dock and he
passed out
i just cannot believe this is happening
where do you guys live
so this is long story short our parents
moved to florida
and la's totally closed we live in l.a
oh we've been here for like two weeks
yeah apparently someone just got bit by
there's so much don't even know you look
at those chaotic places like iguanas
people getting bit by catfish like
everyone goes out it's really strong
it's like hope it's not a thing here
we're all stressed out 24 7.
that's what a girl it's like i'm really
sorry over there oh my gosh that's such
another one all right
let's let's go back to what you were
saying i'm so sorry everything's gonna
be okay
uh i it's this um organization called
raw beauty talks my girlfriend um
founded it and it's pretty much like
celebrities bodies and
all different shapes and colors and it's
she's really really um
she's been through it in her life and so
she speaks from experience but she's in
a whole other place now and she helps so
many people and it's it's incredible and
i loved what she was doing because i had
some pretty serious body dysmorphia from
growing up in a ballet studio
and so i was always like really
vulnerable with her and wanted to help
but she so it was really cool to
actually go on the show
have a platform and then be able to like
share her
her page and what she's doing with so
many people because people have really
really liked her content so it's cool so
that so your friend convinces you to
join
yeah and you you apply you obviously
get it well i did it at first they i was
supposed to be on
pablo season and they didn't call me oh
my god juan
pablo what a dork
[Music]
but then they called me and i went on oh
my god well all i remember is
when you were on because i didn't really
watch the show that much and
i remember i think it was like yours was
the first season i
i had ever seen and you stuck out in
like the best way possible
because i feel like every female there
was very cookie-cutter trying to act as
if like they're gonna be the perfect
wife material but you were just
funny and raunchy and yourself and i was
like
this is amazing this is amazing so
obviously
it worked out in your favor but i feel
like the process of doing the show
can be you know you don't get final edit
and i feel like a lot of situations are
manipulated
yeah was there ever a time where you
know something was put out on tv that
wasn't
you know the truth of what actually
happened or what you wanted to do and
you sort of were put in a position where
you're like [ __ ] i have to do this
because
i mean a little bit yeah
pretty lucky with what they put out on
the bachelor i was like holy [ __ ]
it made me look like a psycho like i
have such a weird sense of humor
and like i like to chirp other girls and
i like to like poke fun but that could
have been like
yeah like you know if they edit it the
right way you could
possibly look like a brilliant yeah so i
was like oh no because the first night
on night one i'm watching the episode
and i'm like uh-oh
i am for sure gonna be the [ __ ] this
season because that's
episode one they like showed me and
making raunchy jokes and saying
things that i was like not giving a [ __ ]
about anything
um but i was actually really fortunate
because i felt like they really did show
who i really was through the season
but on the bachelorette there was so
many times where i was like
hey i did not say that i was saying that
about him and i was talking about this
i was actually crying about my family
not him like
so many things no oh so many
the um i mean the whole controversial
like
me having sex before the fantasy suite
that was totally blown out of proportion
um i'm not gonna deny it because it
still happened but it was blown out of
proportion
right right right so many things but i
mean
you kind of expect that and you sign up
for it too because that's
that's reality tv that's right yeah you
handle it so well and actually i was
asking my sister i was like what other
reality show would you be on
other than like dancing with the stars
you just did that what other show it
doesn't have to be involving like the
bachelor franchise
oh i was like big brother big brother
and one time you know my girlfriend was
on it from
yeah the last yeah honestly annalise
talvera
yeah yes she had the boyfriend the
what's his name
the soccer player she was kind of like
seeing a guy that was super tall you
kind of looked like jason momoa
yeah yeah i've never seen big brother
but she was like the only one wait
i'm showing this up tell me how do you
spell her name do you know
yeah it's a n a l y
s e annelise and then talamera she's not
leathers
hi annaliese no she's oh yeah of course
oh my gosh yes she was so sweet
actually she's she's sweet we actually
went to high school together and so
that's funny that you mentioned that
because i actually never seen
the show before and then i'm like oh my
god this is like the truman show
yeah it is i don't know why i want to go
on it because i would be so exposed with
all of my i'd be like plucking chin
hairs and people be like you're
disgusting
like well that's the thing i didn't
realize that you go online and it's 24
hours like you can watch it even when
it's not on tv
i don't know why i want to i like the
competition aspect of it i like the head
of household i like
i'm really competitive i feel like you
have to have a good social game
to move like to get really far ahead i
just feel like i would enjoy it but i'd
also probably lose my mind
i think you would absolutely win though
you totally would win oh yeah
oh yeah because you have to be you have
to be very smart with your words like
you would you're
very strategic like you still you watch
likes like go into it but you're i can
tell you're very like
okay i make moves eye on the prize i
know what i want
yes that is me thank you
um so i want to talk about your current
relationship with jason
and i sort of feel like you know i don't
would do you think you would have met
this person had you not
started the show like probably not so
sort of like the the stars aligned in a
weird way
did you ever re-watch your season with
jason
um kind of
it's so funny because you say the stars
align it was the wildest thing i've ever
experienced in my life i am such a like
um such a nerd for like crystals and
manifesting
yeah and like believing in the universe
i read books and i just read this book
about
paying attention to signs from the
universe and it was it's called
light is the new black it's incredible
and i was listening to it
kind of to get through up and i was like
oh everything's going to happen for a
reason and i
later on met jason on i was podcasting
with him and i didn't think twice i was
just like oh that guy's great
he should be the bachelor like some
girl's gonna be really lucky to have him
and i didn't think twice about it but i
had just
walked um i okay how do i explain this
shawn
my ex we had a dog tucker and i still
was getting tucker sometimes and i took
tucker for a walk
and i remember looking at the moon and
saying just like
i need so many signs right now to tell
me i'm gonna be okay
and it was like the weirdest thing what
happened
jason and i like we uh we would text
each other like the same thing at the
same time
he told me i reminded him of nala from
lion king
and i was watching lion king on the
plane while he sent that
and she like came at the same time and
then all these weird things
kept happening then i go to get in an
uber
and the uber was late and he was like
i'm so sorry i'm late but
i made a wrong turn and then i passed
the car of my dreams that i'm saving up
for and i think that's a sign from the
universe
and you got to pay attention to those
and i was like yep and then we almost
hit a dog
and the dog was crossing the street and
he was like oh my gosh i used to be so
afraid of dogs but i have one now and i
love her so much i was like oh what's
her name she's like nala
and i'm like uh
just so many things so i actually you
just can't ignore the signs
no there was like hundreds more like it
we got to a point where like this is
actually weird
um so i bought him a picture of the
skyline when the night we met
because when the star was actually
aligned
that is romantic as [ __ ] i'm not
romantic
talk about we want that stuff to happen
to us but
i don't know where to start whether like
you're just like the ultimate romantic
like
i'm not i think you put it out there
though because that's what you wanted
because you know she
there's that whole energy thing when you
put it you want
something to happen like somebody's like
i we're so much we're big on that we're
we used to like do vision boards and
like yes
like we love reading about manifesting
stuff but i mean right now it's kind of
i mean
you guys i see like like little clips
here and there on instagram and you guys
are so
on tick tock like so you please tell me
you're having a baby soon
oh you know what's so interesting is
he so we talk about this all the time
because i have like had baby fever for
probably 10 years now
and i ain't getting any younger you're
going to be such a good mom
oh i like i feel like i was put on this
planet to be a mom like i cannot
and not wait and i hope it happens for
me oh my gosh i've had so many friends
you know
people i know that struggle with
infertility and
like it breaks my heart and i'm just i
hope it's in the cards for me but
um i've told told jason that i've like
had baby fever for so long
and he's really set on having kids he
just is very traditional wants to do it
the right way where i'm like
i don't care all the babies should get
married and then like yeah
i mean my mom had me before the wedding
and yeah she's a little bastard baby
i'm not mad at masturbation
i'm not mad at that um and he was just
like
i think it was a few nights ago he was
talking to a couple of his buddies who
are like ready or one has one
and they were like talking about the
pros and cons and they're like but all
the cons like the pros outweigh like
it's
just so worth it and jason was like i
just don't feel like i'm ready
and he keeps banking on the fact that i
have my eggs frozen
but i'm like that's not a guarantee
that's like a better
plan in like yeah you know and so
last night i'm very much like i used to
never be like this if my boyfriend went
out of town or something i'd like start
getting insecure or i'd be like why
aren't they calling
right i've never been like that once
with jason he's just
i feel so safe with him and and nobody's
ever really made me feel that way
and so he was like i was just letting
him go do his thing he was drinking with
the boys he was going to football at the
football game and he was doing whatever
and he started messaging me out of
nowhere being like i think i'm ready to
have kids
oh my god you manifested that too
that was you i have like a little fetus
in my vision board right wait
hold on i feel like they don't make men
like jason anymore
they don't he's you have any friends for
us
i know help us does he have a brother
i'm like yes but he's his brother is gay
and married
he's truly like i mean don't get me
wrong there are things i could
list i could bring up the things that i
want
close to foreign that's amazing and
honestly you deserve it because
you put it out there you wanted it and
it came back around full circle
one of the cutest things that i saw you
guys do together or
actually that he posted or maybe you
posted was his
reaction to you winning dancing with the
stars literally i just showed my mom i
showed my dad i showed the dog i was
like this is the
cutest thing ever like i need a man to
support me like that like
i want to talk about that whole process
because even today on our walk what did
i say
that i want to do dancing with the stars
thank you listening to me
wow she's been saying this for a while
sorry i'll like
anyway i would love to know because you
were a dancer you said you did ballet
right which i had no idea i didn't know
you were a dancer before yeah my mom was
a professional ballerina and then i did
ballet growing up and then i more went
into the hip-hop side of things i
loved doing hip-hop classes i was part
of a cool company i was like i am going
to be
janet jackson's backup dancer like that
was my whole plan yeah
but the dancing with the stars it's so
funny because
and not to like harp on my old
relationship but i just never felt
supported or like i had a hype man or
someone that was like oh my god you're
killing
it it was kind of like i wanted to feel
guilty for certain things and
i was like when i went into a
relationship with jason i was like kind
of hesitant
because i was like i'm like really
independent i really like doing my own
thing
yeah i feel like i'm on a roll right now
and i've got a lot i want to accomplish
and like i need somebody that's going to
be super encouraging and like
not emasculated or secure and
that's exactly what he is he's just so
secure that makes him the ultimate hype
man because
when i got um asked to go on dancing
with the stars like
his reaction was just as genuine as mine
and he was like
and he just like couldn't believe it he
kept looking at me and like oh my god
like he was so
happy for me and then you know he had to
pick up his life
moved to l.a he had to live in this tiny
little apartment during
covet like in a bubble taking out the
dogs in an apartment like
every two hours our dogs were having
accidents there such a trooper
every night i come home he'd just have a
glass of wine on the table for me like
dinner he rubbed my feet it was
incredible he was a really
i really give him a lot of credit for my
win because i don't think i could have
done that without him
that's incredible yeah that's incredible
you know i think having that
um that person to back you just makes
the whole experience worth it because
you get to share every experience with
them you're sharing the win with them
and i think that's so cool
but you brought up an interesting point
because i sometimes find that
men are often threatened by women that
are independent and on their own
yeah so we will have our businesses
going we'll have our ambitions but they
get threatened by it
yeah and you sort of prior relationships
what advice can you give
to someone even like us that's dealing
with stuff like that it's so hard
because
i don't know if it's like how men were
raised because of their
parents generation or if men are just
wired that way
or if they just like there aren't many
secure guys out there who are like
established in their own [ __ ]
emotionally financially and in all those
ways so
i feel like that's it's you kind of got
to wean out the [ __ ] once like i
like you know i don't know i don't have
crazy negative things to say about my
exes but i definitely
didn't have the type of guys who were
like so secure and level-headed in
themselves that they could celebrate
a woman's success and they always had
that um
like almost like a brainwash that they
had to be the supplier or the supplier
provider
the provider yeah supplier provider
all of them they do the shipping the
packaging
they do it all yeah they showed all that
um
but yeah i think i think it's about
finding a guy who's just so secure in
himself who
is established in what he's doing and is
able to
like like lift you up and celebrate your
wins because
i don't know why that's so hard to find
with saturday then we always say we're
like
you don't need to be the ceo of like no
apple or sorry like something absurdly
ridiculous if you have your own
passion your own thing that you're yeah
it's like you go and you're ambitious
about
that's enough for me it's like and i
think that's enough to make you secure
maybe that comes with age as well it
probably is mature
yeah i really think it does there's a
whole like scientific
something out there about the frontal
lobe and how men's frontal lobe
does not develop until the age of 29 and
that's the decision-making part of the
brain the whole
shebang it's i swear that's true because
i know we've been i mean i'm only 24
she's 22 and so
the guys that we go out with that are
around our age we're just like we're
dating someone that's 16. but i feel
like
i date like a seven-year-old woman so i
need
someone at least 77. no
like like like you yourself you feel
like an old woman
yeah i know so in life hold on you're
not i'm the what are you talking about
you can be the old soul i'll be the
middle-aged soul okay
but like no i feel like that our
maturity level with dating
is much older which is like what we what
we are looking for
yeah but you know maybe palm beach has
those guys
oh around we're trying have you ever
thought of doing um
like a spin-off show with jason
um i mean i go back i got it i think
what caitlyn and jason have a baby
i see i think about this stuff all the
time because i'm like
would i want to do that and put my
relationship under my
microscope microscope because i've
i've been in a situation where all of a
sudden you go overnight from like nobody
knowing who you are to everybody knowing
who you are and it puts a lot of
pressure on you and i put a lot of
pressure on my last relationship
and i get scared so i think i'm a little
jaded about that but i mean again that's
that was out of my control we would be
able to have like the creative control
of our own shoes
totally i don't know it is nice of
seeing your guys's relationship because
it does make girls also look at it and
go or even guys go like that's the
relationship i want so there is positive
benefits to starting it because then
people can watch and be like
but i get scared that everyone will
think i'm mean because i
i'm like on my period or something like
i turn into the devil
and then i'm like what if they catch me
on a couple bad days
and i'm like see all of the comments on
the podcast are like sophia's really
nice this needs a little mean i'm like
i'm just
sarcastic and dry and i know it's hard
to
land with certain yeah yeah we thought
it'd be really fun to play a word
association game with i love this
so we'll do it really quick we'll do it
really quick so yeah think of the first
word
i was excited i was gonna say ben like
big ben
but then that sounded like i was talking
about a guy okay oh okay
that's fine big
ben wine me
love dogs
drunk me
[Laughter]
thirsty
victoria from the seasons bachelor
yes anyway there we go fake
boobs crunchy
cereal i was going to say like my hair
um happy was it happy
oh um
jason he's very happy i love that
beef beef beef
barf
purple
dinosaur barney
good good sweat
okay one word it has to be one word
no you could i started the bed last
night you know when you're hormonal and
you like wake up soaking wet you're like
what the [ __ ]
what the best yes i i sweat the bed the
other night when i was drinking tequila
i woke up i was like what the hell
every time we drink tequila we wake up
in the middle of the night like hot
flash
really crazy yes i don't know yeah we
gotta switch it up maybe
bourbon all right here we go nasty
beef delicious
wine oh good yes boring
sober and unwaxed
my vagina there we go oh my god
what does everybody say that no you know
what you're the first person we asked so
we love this she's like oh [ __ ]
this for like test run let's see how it
goes
oh my god that was you played that game
the best so far by the way
they're so hot really yes you gave the
most honest answers
oh i thought they were so lame i'm like
i could have done better oh they were
holding their guys
okay we'll do another one next time yeah
i love where to start
i this is literally probably one of my
favorites i know you are so much fun
yes thank you that's so nice
it's sometimes you get people on and
they don't
exactly give you know as an interviewer
it's hard it's hard to get and you're
just so
lovely and nice and funny and thank you
and i know a lot of people listening are
going to love you so
we really appreciate you coming that's
very sweet well i'll have to have you
both on my podcast because i feel like
you're the kind of girls that my girls
would love too
oh my god we'll be there with the line
i'd love to yes we'll have a wine
a wine date podcast let's do it i love
that perfect
well thank you so much for coming on
tell jason and the dog i say hi
i will thank you guys so much enjoy
being bit like catfish
oh my god
[Music]